Once you've produced some summary statistics,
you'll write a brief blog post explaining the results of your analyses from
assignment three, incorporating the visualization you made for assignment four.
And, also your newly produced map for these findings.
When this is complete, you should have an interesting and informative blog post
about the New York City subway that you can share with your friends and family.
Writing this blog post will give you some good practice communicating your
findings to other people, whether they be other data scientists or
less technical business partners.
This is one of the most important skills a data scientist can
have when working in the real world, since not everybody's a data expert.
This blog post should also be an excellent first entry in to
your portfolio of work as a data scientist,
which you can share with other people when they ask what projects you've done.
I've posted an example blog post on the class forum,
in case you need some inspiration.